with more on the countdown to the maiden
launch of nasa's huge moon rocket it's
set for monday we are taking you behind
the scenes now inside artemis mission
control at nasa's johnson space center
in houston mark strossman sat down with
the lead flight director to talk about
the historic mission and what's at stake
and there is mr straussman again hello
from florida mark good morning
mr jacob good morning to you you know
this
instant the instant that that rocket
behind me lifts off control of this
flight shifts from here in florida to
houston now there are no astronauts
aboard this mission but the lead flight
director and his team know
this mission really has to go well it
just has to go well for astronauts to
land on the moon
anytime soon
this is all brand new to us everything
rick lebron works every day to give
america the moon
now 60 he's the artemis one lead flight
director the guy in the hot seat guiding
nasa's most ambitious lunar mission in a
half century we gotta have a successful
flight before we put the astronauts on
the next mission otherwise you're not
putting astronauts on the next mission
you can practice all you want to go to
the moon but the launch is game time
it's going to be very different and then
you know
you hear the pucker factor it'll be
there we met lebron inside artemis
mission control at the johnson space
center in nearly four decades with nasa
he's helped assemble the international
space station and served as flight
director for the space shuttle program
analysis has cleared us for four homes
burns but no one working on artemis one
not lebrode not anyone on his team has
ever worked on a moon shot i mean we
were alive a lot of us last time we put
boots on the moon but we were very young
apollo 17 december 1972
astronaut gene cernan's boot prints were
the last left in lunar dust budget
issues and fading public interest put an
end to the apollo moon missions and
closed the book on one of mankind's
great achievements until now where do
you start you just dust off the old
apollo manuals
you know a lot of our guys did the bro
took us up one floor to the stage of so
much space history the iconic apollo
mission control room it's just amazing
to see the technology and what we were
able to do with it in here the united
states beat the soviets to the moon
using rotary dial phones and slide rules
when you look at old footage of the
apollo
era what jumps out at you bermuda
is green well
it's always interesting to see people
smoking in mission control you know we
haven't done it we don't do that anymore
but you know there's a lot of
similarities it's a laser focus the
flight control team they will do
whatever it takes to get it done that
part hasn't changed even the slightest
bit
launching on top of the most powerful
rocket nasa's ever built artemis 1 will
send a capsule called orion on a
trajectory to the moon orion will fly
within 60 miles of the lunar surface
then push forty thousand miles beyond
the moon for space high drama its
glimpse back on earth after orbiting the
moon orion will re-enter earth's
atmosphere for the missions priority one
test whether the capsule's heat shield
can withstand temperatures of 5 000
degrees about half as hot as the surface
of the sun i mean it's coming back at
some ridiculous speeds i think it's 11.6
kilometers per second 25 000 miles an
hour yeah yeah it gets really really hot
we got to make sure that's going to
support the re-entry if artemis 1
succeeds it would pave the way for human
flights to the moon including a lunar
landing later this decade and how
hurtful
to the program would it be if it doesn't
go right i can't tell you that i don't
know but it conceivably could be it
could end the program it could you just
never know until you get that situation
i hope we don't have to worry about that
it's my goal no pressure right from this
room lebron and his team will both lead
and follow the future of nasa's human
space exploration starting with artemis
one's liftoff and after almost 40 years
of nasa what's that moment going to be
like
i i can't even i can't even begin to
think about it honestly i've gotten
emotional my old age so i got to be
careful here it'll be very rewarding
it'll be very special for sure you said
emotional why emotional you reflect back
on how blessed i am and even be in this
position to be able to do this yeah it's
pretty
it's pretty big deal
big moment for him and for the entire
team i asked lebron whether he has even
if he has even more respect now for the
apollo era engineers now that he's
directing a launch to the moon himself
for the first time and he said you know
absolutely for a couple of reasons uh
one is remember the apollo era folks
were making it up as it went along it
had never been done before and then also
remember just the level of 1960s
technology it really was remarkable that
they pulled it off as quickly as they
did and as well as it did back in the
60s jamie
it is mind-boggling to think that that
all was able to come together i love
that he called it the pucker factor i i
can't imagine how stressed out he is but
he does have a little bit more
technology as you just pointed out mark
that was a great conversation got him
crying at the end there he's getting a
little sentimental in his old age but it
is a really big deal yep
mark thank you